voilà et on retrouve sous le soleil
couchant de cannes et de gauche à droite
sami bouajila jamel debbouze et roschdy
zem bonsoir à vous trois questions avoue
djamel d'abord vous vous êtes beaucoup
investi dans ce projet pourquoi savent
apparaît comme une évidence d'abord
parce que je suis acteur et que rachid
bouchareb a proposé un rôle en béton
armé avec des vrais enjeux et des vrais
objectifs et comme régis bouchard avait
eu une boule d'humanité et qu'il est
qu'il a une conscience politique en
béton armé ça m'a paru évident arnaque
ou re 10 m
vous connaissiez vous même avant de lire
le scénario vous connaissiez l'épopée de
ces hommes pendant la deuxième guerre
je la connaissais pas dans le détail je
savais qu'il y avait eu cette épopée
mais grâce aux archives que nous a
transmis rachid bouchareb et j'aimerais
aller les producteurs on a pu fouiller
un peu plus et se rendre compte un peu
de ce qui s'était passé de l'implication
qu'ils avaient eu pour la deuxième
guerre mondiale et surtout chose c'est
que on s'est rendu compte à quel point
ils ne sont pas à aucun moment il se
sentit et se sont sentis victimes de
sédières ils ont ils se sentent acteurs
de cette guerre et c'est ça surtout qui
nous a qui nous a motivés sami bouajila
oui oui alesi jamel non non je dis c'est
surtout que dans nos livres d'histoire
malheureusement l'hérault le lourd
semble ne nous ressemble pas ou ou très
peu et que ça ça nous a paru évident de
défendre de défendre c'est ces
tirailleurs on a été discuté avec eux
ils sont ils sont cloîtrés dans des
foyers sonacotra il collectionne des
paquets de pâtes aujourd'hui c'était ça
c'est pour nous un véritable honneur de
pouvoir leur rendre hommage
alors justement ce film nous l'avait
fait pour qu'il vous l'avez fait pour
eux ou vous l'avez fait pour les jeunes
qui effectivement souvent ne connaissent
connaissent mal cette histoire oui
justement mais c'est lié bain les jeunes
on le fait pour eux mais par incidence
on le fait aussi pour nous bien
évidemment c'est juste encore une fois
et j'aimerais on se répète c'est juste
encore une fois un hommage d'abord à ces
gens là bien sûr comme l'a dit jamel est
aussi
un pan de notre histoire un pan de notre
histoire qui nous manque pour pour
constituer une identité c'est
visiblement tous les cas quelque chose
de criant pour toute notre génération
on a envie de retrouver notre histoire
on a envie de on a envie de se découvre
de se découvrir parce qu'on est d'abord
ce qu'on était aussi quoi oui puisque
c'est important de préciser c'est qu'il
s'agit de l'histoire de france
donc c'est votre histoire cc c'est un
pan parmi tant d'autres qui illustre
l'histoire coloniale française ne
pouvant pas dire en quelques mots que ce
film c'est un peu un post-it de
l'histoire de france
espèce de rappel il ya des choses qui
ont été faites il ya des choses qui ont
été faites avant des choses qui seront
fonds qui seront faites sûrement après
on fait partie intégrante de l'histoire
on avance et on espère juste que la
lumière sera faite sur ces tirailleurs
qui sont sacrifiés pour la france et
c'est grâce à eux aujourd'hui on a
l'opportunité de répondre à vos
questions de se coucher à das est alors
rachid bouchareb le metteur en scène il
dit ce n'est pas un film
revanchard le propos n'est pas
revanchard mais quand on le voyait de
l'amertume quand même en aucun cas en
aucun cas je la sors moi ce qui m'a le
plus frappé ce qui m'a ce qui m'a le
plus touché c'est si encore une fois en
discutant avec ses tirailleurs en aucun
cas ils sont rancuniers ni revanche a
encore aujourd'hui comblée chine ne
demande rien à personne
on a pu constater en corse après midi il
y en a trois qui sont avec nous qui
monta les marches non jamais jamais on a
pu sentir ni d'amertume il a encore bien
au contraire
et encore une fois quand on dit c'est un
pan de notre histoire c'est pas de notre
histoire nous autres français d'origine
maghrébine c'est de notre histoire de
notre histoire de france histoire
commune qui nous appartient un titre que
charlemagne ou encore montesquieu ou
encore marie antoinette voilà impeccable
jamais là sur l'histoire incollable si
je peux me permettre vraiment on peut
pas on peut pas vivre le présent et et
aborder le futur ce sans connaître notre
passé donc c'est ça nous paraissait
logique de faire ce film alors une
dernière chose une dernière question le
film a reçu un accueil favorable il ya
eu des applaudissements
ce matin à l'issue de la projection ça
vous fait chaud au coeur a laissé
répondre que c'est ce film a pu se faire
a pu se monter et c'est déjà une
victoire en soi donc
le fait aujourd'hui d'avoir une vitrine
comme celle de cannes c'est ce n'est que
du bonus moi je voulais juste saluer
tous les tirailleurs dans tous les
foyers du monde qui nous regardent
ce film a été fait en partie pour vous
et et on voulait simplement avec les
acteurs leur dire qu'on les avait en
effet oublié pas voilà merci aux trois
comédiens entretien enregistré juste
avant la montée des marches puisque
toute l'équipe est actuellement en
pleine projection à cannes